it's not about when the entire islands
are underwater it's well before that
it's going to be the crisis and it's
already happening what we are facing at
the moment is Sylvia flooding it's gone
into the freshwater ponds and that's how
people get their drinking water have you
spoken as people in the scientific
community that have given you some sort
of a timeframe given the scenarios and
the projections put forward by the
science our Islands will be under water
and so the question is what do we do
about it at the moment internally we are
relocating communities from certain
parts of the island to where the water
has not come up but our long-term
strategy is something that I've been
discussing internationally because we we
have to come to accept the reality that
we may not be able to accommodate all of
our people
we have adopted a policy of migration
with dignity we bought a piece of land
in GG so that if now people choose to
migrate today they can do it hmm
they must do it as a method of choice
Rob got grandchildren
I've got 12 grandchildren I'd like to be
able to go away knowing that they will
continue to have a phone
Islands in the Pacific we're paradise in
Korea through alpha log we have
sea-level rise coming into the farmlands
coming into the homes this is
unbelievable
when was this an intact island with
homes on it
how long ago 12 years ago when you can
there were people living here so within
the 12-year period this is the result
it's just a small picture of one place
the small island nations contribute the
least to the causes of climate change
actually going to feel the worst impacts
the worst scenarios because of global
warming